so just yesterday was January 1st
everybody had their own New Year
resolution we're all excited how are
your goals looking so far because it's
no longer January 1st here's a kicker
for two or three years every year I
would say this is my year this is my
year this is my year nothing would
change results was the same finally I
had to learn what drove me at that age
so what drove the 25 year old pbd what
drove me at 30 what drove me at 35 what
drove me at 40 and what drives me today
if you don't fully know what drives you
in order to get better results at the
age you're at at the current current
state you're at it may be very different
I created a quiz that at pbdquiz.com for
you to take to learn exactly what drives
you at the current age you're at if you
want to find that I'll click on the link
above or below go take that quiz I'll
see you there